Today, Wizards showed off what looks to
be the majority of the new and returning
mechanics and upcoming card types for
Avatar the Last Air Bender set. And
there's a surprising amount of rules to
cover. So, let's jump into it. Firstly,
we finally learned what the elemental
bending is all about. Let's go through
them. Starting with air bending.
Airbending is an ability that says,
"Exile target permanent. While it is
exiled, its owner may cast it from exile
for two generic mana." Now, there's only
been two airbending cards previewed thus
far. And looking at those, they will
specify what you can target with the
airbending.
So, just be on the lookout for that.
From a standard perspective, these cards
go great with warp, but they go even
better with the overlords.
Next, we have water bending, which can
be found on activated abilities. It
says, "While paying a water bending
cost, you can tap your artifacts and
creatures to help. Each one pays for one
generic." So effectively this is extra
convoke for activated abilities.
Right now generating artifacts, clues,
landers, munitions, treasures, etc. is
really easy. But the thing you need to
keep an eye on, and I can't believe I'm
saying this because neither of these
sets are out yet, and there's a clash of
IPs, the webs slinging mechanic from the
Spider-Man set cares about tapped
creatures. So, we'll likely see more
synergies in the coming weeks when the
Spider-Man set
when the Spider-Man previews officially
start.
Moving on, we have Earthbending.
Earthbending X means target land you
control becomes a 000 creature with
haste that is still a land. Put X + one
+ one counters on it. Now this is my
favorite part. When it dies or is
exiled, return it to the battlefield
tapped. Yes, finally. One of the biggest
drawbacks with animating lands was
immediately opening them up to be
targeted by creature removal. With
earthbending, that completely mitigates
that risk. Now, I'm not saying I want to
see this every time we get a land
animating effect. It's just cool to see
Watsi explore this design space. And
from what we've seen so far, to the
first metal bender, is shaping up to be
my favorite card from the set.
The last elemental bending to cover is
firebending.
Firebending X means whenever this
creature attacks, add X red mana. This
mana lasts until the end of combat.
So firebending is clearly excellent for
aggressive decks as you can use the mana
you generate when you attack to pay for
your pump or burn spells. I also really
like that it's perfect fuel for the new
card, Fated Firepower, an enchantment
with an X in its cost that you can use
all of that excess mana and then
massively increase your damage output.
Now, with all the bending techniques
announced, we can finally start to work
out how hard will it be to flip Avatar
Ang. And currently, it does seem like
it's going to take quite a bit of mana
to do so. Fire bending is easy enough
because it's built into Ang and all you
have to do is attack. Water bending can
also be cheap to do. It's earth bending
and air bending that we'll still need to
see more cards for us to tell.
Also, I get my vindication moment. We
have the base version of Avatar Ang. And
remember that I did a short about
searing touch and ang and all those
comments telling me, "Oh, it doesn't
work like that or what's will change the
rules." If we look at Ang master of
elements, it has reminder text which
says this can reduce generic costs.
So you know what that means? Anyone who
commented that I was wrong, it's off to
the revolving cells with you. And yes,
of course, read F10 is among those
comments.
Now, let's talk about some card types.
First, there's the ally card type, and
we haven't seen proper ally support in a
main set since 2016's Oath of the Gate
Watch. Qatara, the Fearless, is an
excellent ally card, doubling up any
ally triggers, and there are a number of
cards that generate ally tokens, too.
So, it's fair to expect plenty more ally
support to come.
The next card type I did not have on my
bingo card was lessons. A card type that
first appeared in 2021's Stricks Haven.
The card type paired with the keyword
learn. When you cast a card with learn,
you could get a lesson card from your
sideboard and put it into your hand or
discard a card and draw a card.
Now, this is the biggest change with the
avatar lessons is that for the first
time, some of the lessons are instance.
In Stricks Haven, all of the lesson
cards were sorceries.
But what's most interesting is there
won't be any cards with learn in this
set. So, they're clearly saving that
mechanic for the 2026 Stricks Haven set.
The last return card type we need to
cover before I jump into some rule stuff
is shrines. Shrines are a returning card
type, so go Shintai players, rejoice. As
we can see on the Southern Air Temple,
they're still legendary enchantments,
but this time around, the shrine has an
ETB trigger and also triggers when
another shrine enters. So, we can expect
to see at least one cycle of shrines.
The quick rules thing I wanted to cover
was around the new card, the rise of
Sozen, a six- mana saga that transforms
into fire lord so players are already
asking if the color identity of this
card is mono black or red black. I can
confirm that this is a mono black card.
The important rule to remember is that
reminder text, the text written in
italics and parentheses, is not rules
text and has no functional impact on the
game. This is likened to blind obedience
and trinisphere. Both of these cards
have mana symbols in their reminder
text, but reminder text does not impact
color identity.
On the flip side, we have the new card
from the Avatar Jumpstart set, Fire Lord
Ozai.
This card's color identity is black red
because this time around the red mana
symbol is written into the rules text of
the card, not the reminder text.
So, that's all the rules and mechanics
you need to know about for the avatar
set so far. Let me know what your
favorite card is in the comments down
below. As always, be sure to like the
video if you learned something and
subscribe because if you don't, I'll
sacrifice Appa to the Fire Lord. Thanks
for watching and I'll see you in the
next one.
Hey, editor attack on cardboard here. I
I just need to fill some time so I can
hit 8 minutes and get the sweet sweet
mid rolls. Uh, if you've made it this
far in the video, let me know what you
think about these slightly less
intensive edited videos. Uh, just so I
can obviously pump these out real
quickly when some news comes through. If
you like to see this stuff, because
obviously I can turn these around in uh,
you know, within 12 hours of the news
being announced, let me know in the
comments down below. Thanks for
listening to the secret message. Thanks
for letting me get my sweet, sweet ad
revenue. Uh, bless your packs. Thank you
very much. Have a good